brothers and sisters and dear friends
this individual on my left exposed
israel and their big plans to make
israel look positive here's what he had
to say let's watch it together israeli
government is flying out like
celebrities for free out there
to do a tour for free
and it's on the house they apply you
first class the whole thing and i go
it's free they go yeah
it's not free
because when you land there
they go you have to everyday tweet
positive things
about israel yeah right yeah and i just
felt so uneasy uneasy about it i don't
know much about it i just know that
they're in conflict but i did i did what
they said it was just basically you know
oh um
palestinians i know israel's a beautiful
country yeah that's probably true that's
true it is true but then it's like i had
to tag the government in it or whatever
oh that's crazy the israeli government
yeah oh that's weird as [ __ ] yeah and it
was just like every day it was just
nonsense you were cucking for the
israeli government yeah but i wish i
hadn't gone really he's clearly saying
that he was invited and they're inviting
many public figures famous how
whoever they are and all they have to do
is they're going to pay for the tickets
their hotel everything covered all we
want you to do is go around take
pictures and say positive stuff
as you can see guys this shows the
guilty conscious this shows that they
know the whole world knows what kind of
a
scums they are that they kill innocent
babies children and blow them into
pieces and may allah do the same to
their state i mean inshallah yeah
this shows you how wild they are imagine
a
a wife beater yes imagine a thief
imagine someone who kills people imagine
somebody murders that's all his job and
he goes and pays people and be like hey
listen when you come and chill with me
just say positive stuff about me it just
shows how scum you are that you're going
to go to the level of pain someone to
hide your atrocities
never that's never going to happen and
us our duty is what to talk about it and
any public figure that you see going
there and putting positive stuff stick
it on them because it seems like jordan
peterson installed himself to them uh
very easily he's done a u-turn and we
don't put trust in these people like
allah says in the quran allah makes it
very clear and allah he says always the
truth yes because when you take them as
intimate friends look what they do
okay we don't need him who cares like
nobody needs needs him as you can see
guys subhanallah and before guys i carry
on inshallah please download
uh
building up we need promises our quran
catching dust
dust is the basic
you can get it download it for free try
it and test it for yourself inshallah
and that's all i have to say brothers
and sisters inshallah we i have to put
these people to account inshallah
logan paul if you see any of these big
figures go in this we can positively
stick it on them inshallah that's all i
have to say brother sisters and allah
says in the quran never think that allah
is unaware of what the evil jews do for
he delays them for a day that their eyes
will stay in horror stare in horror and
inshallah on that day the believers
would see them
in sha'a starring in horror till next
time assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
to help those in afghanistan who have
suffered the earthquake and are homeless
before the video starts please donate to
that in the description box below enjoy
the video may allah bless you guys